you stopping at holders
all lines except the two-30 848 and as
of right now that remains the case all
of the lines are stopping at Fulton
Street
except for the two three
passing through the station while the
police conduct their scenes for crime
investigation we did have two chains
that we had to deal with when that train
when that poor father first came true
from the police that there was the issue
on the 2/3 power he had to change the
deal so again acting quickly and
credibly stopped my start with their
professionalism we had one train to
evacuate to upholstery that was done in
orderly fashion
it was done quickly customs were taken
off the train and evacuated to street
level we have no other train that had to
be taken back to Wall Street but again
there were no injuries it was done
calmly and it was done professionally so
like the Chairman I would like to thank
employees for the professional way that
they dealt with this incident I would
also like to commend your
identify this as an issue and the way
they calmly went about dealing with the
incident and bringing in the bomb squad
to make sure the customers New Yorkers
were kept safe guess what my messages
will be this
shows the benefit of everyone working
together we have around 6 million riders
on the subway every day and that's six
million pairs of eyes and ears
we work together if we see something say
something
in New York say so that's that's where
we are that's the timeline
again we gather around 7 o'clock
initially only impacted the lines 9 7 3
rapidly progressing by passing the other
line
Alliance back Oh 848 to three remain by
passing through this station
so
mal white
the dark hair
and card
very short of quality because
right now
because of the time rush hour
the item
the third thing is the kind
why is he placing them
or officers
idea that
probably
but certainly company with money
[Music]
the timing and the placement and the
items
Karin is right now as the hopes of the
Vice
that's the investigative category
identify undefined
as you all know
part of our creepiness
and everything around
that both like what about
still assessing it
you know right now what we have is
two of them are connected
[Music]
we can get that Briana
except for the two three line
[Music]
and we expect that service
so you
take the question from crown of the
shopping cart he places it on the ground
he does that again
I don't know what the deliberate weather
we're and
the public
who's guarding item living
together we're going to have to identify
an interview over time
by apart
counter-terrorism control in the
we're closed today
alert public
assessing the team
threat
America response
but separate
[Music]
a part of life when you see Isis like
that
I
refuse
context know what they're looking for
he was there
yeah in the friends
the back credit people
everybody then when there was
[Music]
we should approach please officer
we send it down to their home so they
have this photo they know the
again
you know the fact behind it
somebody put out
I picked them up
that video of me
[Music]
that's it